thanks for the interest Sam so I might
go on I'm the creative director at
quartz and I think I heard there's a few
people from the court Surratt see in the
audience yes no no that's fine too so
right so I'll give you a quick intro and
tell you what quartz is so quartz was
started about five years ago we're
essentially a global news site we
believe in the free movement of people
free movement of Commerce free movement
of information and and the thing about
quartz is basically we believe that we
make really big decisions with our heart
and really small decisions with data and
that's the kind of thing that informs
everything that we do in quartz all the
content that we make and essentially how
we how we've gotten where we've gotten
in the last five years
so basically we're guide to the new
global economy that's our tagline that's
what we do we're writers journalists UX
people engineers etc so what I want to
talk about today is I basically set up
little quizzes little questions little
things that you can take here back to
whatever your business is whatever you
create and you can kind of take these
and help apply this UX to make what you
do better if you're kind of on board
with the quartz philosophy and you think
it's gonna work for you I can tell you
you know it works for us we've been
incredibly successful and what I'm gonna
run through today are the kind of things
that we really think and talk and care
about at quartz and this is how we make
everything that we make so very quickly
what do we make at quartz so we have
quartz which is QC calm we've just
launched quartz at work which is a site
for working better we've launched quartz
E which is our lifestyle site we also
have several different emails we have
the quartz native app and then we have
Atlas which is an open-source tool that
we use to make charts a lot of people
around the world use that to do
visualizations and then we also have the
bot studio which we run but with a grant
from the knight foundation and what
we're doing there is we're we're
experimenting with new technology to
figure out how you can take that
technology and use it to make both
journalism and content better so we're
trying to figure out you know what is
the next thing so basically that's my
pitch for quartz but QZ calm and you
know anything you
to know and learn you can you can check
it out there so the most important thing
I think when when we talk about content
in some ways I know this is Khan Khan
I'll probably get get eggs thrown at me
for this
I kind of hate the word content in a way
because it sort of divorces what you're
creating from what it should be which
which is creating something that
generates feelings and people because
ultimately what we think about it course
and when you're creating content the
thing that you want to do with that
content is actually create goodwill and
what I'm what I mean by that
specifically is when someone interacts
with something that you make and put out
from your brand the most important thing
you want them to walk away from is
feeling good about your brand and you
know and I think when when we were in
such like a data-driven world with
content and everything is driven by
metrics you know a lot of times we as
marketers as content creators will will
do things that may help our bottom line
that may help the numbers and the
metrics look good or drive some kind of
numerical success but they leave the
user coming away with with a bad feeling
about the brand and if a user has a bad
feeling about your brand that's
something that's really really hard to
to come back from so our philosophy when
we make content is just always make sure
that the user comes away with goodwill
that they feel good about the brand that
it's always a good experience even
sometimes when we have to sacrifice what
might be you know a metric or something
numerical or we have to take the harder
way around to make sure that they feel
good so the three things I want to talk
about to start with are the big over
pinning philosophies of exactly how we
get into the weeds with making content
at quartz and so like I said you can
kind of think of these in a way it's
like little quiz are almost like if
you're kind of like a philosophy nerd
like a Socratic method that you can take
back to run content through like
basically if you ask yourself these
questions if when you're making
something if you kind of run through
this and you really apply some rigor to
it whether you take one of these things
or none of these things or all of these
things if you just sort of examine what
you're making through these lenses I
definitely for us it helps us improve
what we do and these are sort of the
guiding lights so the first one here is
is aim for the intersection and this is
really really important and when you aim
for the intersection what I mean to say
there's things that you want to say as a
brand as a content creator and then you
know there's actually the things that
your audience cares about and those are
generally you know they're not the same
thing like what you want to tell your
audience and what you wouldn't want them
to do isn't necessarily the best thing
for your audience so basically how do
you find the intersection of these two
things so what we do at courts is we
have something we call obsession mapping
which is kind of like a really fun
exercise and the more you do it the
better you get I mean you can do this at
one person but it actually works best
with a couple of people or a group
basically everybody gets a piece of
paper you write it one person writes the
top of it the audience one person writes
the top of it the brand you go off into
your corner and write the things that
you care about what you know what is
important to your brand and then
somebody else is writing you know what's
important to your audience like what do
they actually care about and it's
probably not the things that you
consider a KPI and when you've done this
you can take these two things you come
back together and when you find two
obsessions that match then you found
something that is worth creating content
around so obsession mapping really
drives a tone of what we do at courts
because we run our newsroom by
obsessions we write about the things
that were obsessed about and then we go
out we talk to our audience we find out
what they're obsessed about and the two
things where they meet that's how we
find the intersection and for us this
has been a really powerful tool that's
why our journalists don't have beats
they have obsessions and same thing with
our content we write about things that
we're obsessed about that our audience
is also obsessed about so this one here
is one that I feel really strongly about
which is audiences have values but
people have value and I think the way
that we the way that many people or we
look at audiences right you define an
audience by a bunch of numbers you know
it's how old people are it's where they
live it's what they do it's how much
money they make it's all these things
but actually an audience is really a set
of feelings you know a set of like
shared common interest and shared common
things so one of the things that we
challenge ourselves with here and this
is another exercise that you can do is
can you define your audience in a really
clear and thorough way without using any
numbers or data you know can you
describe them you know can you think if
you are if you were a novelist or if
you're a writer can you write about your
audience and tell
about the things that they feel deeply
about and care deeply about without
using a number and I think one when you
start to do an exercise like this and
you take the numbers away from your
audience you start to understand that
they're not just a conglomeration of
data you know that they're actually real
people and there's things that they care
about and when you can bring your
content into a place to reach them based
on the feelings not on the numbers
that's going to get you much further
because when people care deeply about
things they tend to take action more
often which is something that we that we
found at courts and I think this is you
know it's tough I know that we're most
of us likely what the content we put out
is probably 90 or 95 percent digital and
that metrics are really important but
what I would just say here is I think
this is a word the exercise to take the
time to see what it would look like if
you if you measured your audience in a
way that was not numerical that was just
based on sort of gut feelings almost the
way things were done 30 years ago before
we had digital metrics so the other big
arching thing that we think about is
content is a product and in the sense of
we never think of just writing or making
a video or making an infographic and
putting it in a container we design and
think about everything from the ground
up is a cohesive piece so basically when
we have a story that we want to tell we
sit down and we think right at the
beginning you know what is the best way
to tell this story and I mean that can
be anything sometimes it might be text
sometimes it might be text and video
sometimes it might be a website
sometimes it might be an app but
whatever it is at the beginning of the
process we have our product team or
engineers our designers in there so I
think it's worth thinking about you know
if you're someone who all of your
content goes directly on a website or it
goes directly on a blog or it goes
directly on medium it would be worth
thinking about are there other ways that
you can communicate the same message
through a different format or make
something new to start with so we feel
really strongly that content is as a
product is what defines the thing and if
you kind of think of the way that people
consume right and consume reading online
you know it's a lot like walking into a
store there's tens of thousands of
things out there on the shelf and
they're all packaged a certain way so
you can do the exercise and think of
well how is my thing packaged
what when people just take a quick look
at it that one second glance or they see
it in a search what is the what is the
packaging what is the product that is
differentiating my my offering my
content from other people and if you
conceive it as a product and not just a
piece of writing you know it's no longer
500 words or three images it's actually
a complete thing that you're designing
from the ground up this is a place where
we've also had a really strong amount of
success by having that product thinking
and that's also why I think another
thing that we do different is our
engineering and our UX teams are
integrated with the content teams and we
all work together to build these things
from day one so in the next part what
makes a good content user experience so
for us there's three things it needs to
be consumable it needs to be accessible
and it needs to be respectful sorry the
letters dropped on that slide I guess
designing for the big screen as I talked
about design a good content clearly fail
fail so this is gonna sound really dumb
but the most important thing about
anything you're putting out is it needs
to be consumable and what I mean is can
people actually access and see and read
what it is that you're putting out and
this sounds really dumb like well of
course people can consume it but if you
actually I'm sure you've had this
experience there's so many places you
can go on the web where you're
interested in reading something and you
actually can't consume that thing and it
could be because the page doesn't load
it could be because there's so many
pop-ups that it's unreadable it could be
because you have to enter your email
before they let you read the thing it
could be because you have to watch 30
seconds of pre-roll before you see the
video but for us making it consumable is
important because if a user is not able
to consume what they want from you
immediately they're going to leave and
they're never going to come back so you
know give yourself like you know draw a
hard line in the sand here is if you
look at what you're putting out there
and say is it actually consumable or are
we doing things to generate metrics to
generate signups to generate whatever it
is we want to do some kind of dark
pattern behavior on our content to get
people to do this because for us it's
all about making it consumable it's the
reason why our courts you know we don't
take any IAB ads it's all sort of done
in-house
make it a good experience so I would
take the challenge here can you go and
make sure that what you're putting out
in the world is something you know that
people can actually see and another
obsession that we have at quartz is its
page loading look we are absolutely
maniacally obsessed with seeing how fast
we can make the pages load and you know
generally when they when they do
different sort of independent studies
we're usually like in the top 10 or top
15 places you know for journalism as far
as making the site read so I would say
here you know when was the last time you
actually checked the site load speed of
your site and you know all the different
things that can slow it down it's worth
going through and see you know can I
make this load faster because the faster
you can make the page page load the more
consumable what you're putting out there
is going to be so the next one here is
it accessible can people actually get to
this and I think you know increasingly
as the world has become really really
connected I think as as content people
especially content people if most of us
here are from the US you know we're all
generally on pretty fast internet
connections we all generally have newer
devices like the newer operating systems
but that's actually not the case for a
vast majority of people globally so you
know what you're putting out there isn't
accessible is it accessible to people on
low bandwidth connections you know are
people who have poor connectivity are
they able to read what it is that you're
putting out there another one is what
about people who use adaptive devices do
you make anything for people who use
screen readers do you make anything for
people who have auditory impairment do
you make any concession for people who
use adaptive devices we're really
obsessed with thinking about making we
feel really strongly that everything we
create is worth putting out into the
world so by doing that we make sure that
it's accessible that the the largest
number of people regardless of whatever
digital impediment they have are able to
do this and I mean there are w3c
standards that are out there that are a
really good starting place for you to
look in if you go they can you know you
can do an audit of your site and I think
you if this is something you haven't
investigated you might be surprised at
how inaccessible your content is to
people in certain places depending on
bandwidth and the types of devices they
use and the other thing I would say here
is like
even though right now this doesn't seem
like a huge thing in the US if you're
building a business for the long term
and you think a year from now two years
from now five years from now you're
looking to have a global audience this
is something you should really take care
of now because people are gonna come
back to your legacy content at some
point and they're not going to be able
to access it because they're somewhere
outside the US so when you go there to
build that audience you should be
prepared for all these different
scenarios to look into so is their
content respectful so when you read an
article that's like 33 ways to tie your
shoelaces like is that respectful of the
reader no no one needs 33 ways maybe you
need one or maybe you need to and you
know respect for the user for the reader
is really important because like me you
know I'm a marketing person as well and
we all sort of have our goals that we're
driving towards but again those goals
might not really be what would that user
trying to do so I think if you put
yourself in the shoes of your users and
say do I do I respect my user is what
I'm doing good for the user or is it
good for me at first this can be a
little bit of a bitter pill to swallow
especially if you're in a metrics driven
business especially if you're doing a
start but I think what we found work for
us is that courts we've always been
respectful of the user since day one and
even when it's tough you know we've hung
onto that and stayed the course that we
will never do anything that is not
respectful to the user and what it's
done is over the last five years we've
been able to build again build that
goodwill and build people who just have
so much love for what we do at courts
because we're always respectful both in
what we write but also how we present it
to them so I would think you know
wherever you can you might have some
idea like you know what this article
needs to be 500 words and I would make
the counter-argument if you could cut
that down to one sentence and the user
the reader comes away with something
really valuable from that one sentence
that's gonna make them love what you're
doing and love your brand more than just
trying to fill up space or we just have
a posting schedule or we have a social
media schedule so I think if you really
think tough about what being respectful
of a user is you can sort of start to
make these decisions and I think
brands and companies that are in it for
the long haul traditionally and now and
in the past always have respect for
their user and they and they do what's
right for the user in the reader so
basically now we can get to a little bit
of of the tactical piece you know how do
we do some of these things you know very
much in a tactical sense so basically
how do you create a good content user
experience for us and from a technical
side there's three things that I think
anyone in this room can look at you know
this afternoon or when they go home
tonight that you might be able to
immediately improve on and might help
you right off the bat if you if you
investigate into some of these three
things so the first one is readability
so essentially readability is you know
when we talked about is your thing
consumable a big part of that is
readability and if you go out onto the
web there are a lot of readability
offenders and what I mean by that is
readability means you should have a
white background with black text or a
black background with white text as a
second option and making that change if
you don't have it is huge and when when
you go to sites that have you know
pattern backgrounds or really busy UX or
really funky fonts that aren't ones that
you see those are real tough readability
challenges and I and I see tons and tons
of them out there because again you get
into your mind like oh wow it would be
really cool if we had like our company
logo running on the background here it'd
be really cool if we had like dancing
cats and all this stuff but really if
somebody is coming to hear what you have
to say they just want to read the thing
so I don't think there's any shame in
having you know just white white
background black text I mean that even
goes back to you know David Ogilvy said
that 50 years ago for print that that's
how it should always be because if
people can't read the thing they can't
see it so I think just really thinking
about the colors and fonts that you use
for text is especially important again
this sounds like everyone's probably
rolling their eyes like of course I know
that but if you know I see it out there
every single day and there's things that
I want to read and I'm not gonna call
any sites or some sites I think the
journalism is really good and I
literally physically can
not read what they're saying on there so
it'd be worth doing a little bit of a
readability audit on your content when
you put it out there so navigation I
think there's really two two things that
navigation needs to be doing when you're
talking about content so the first thing
that navigation needs to do is it needs
to let the user know what they are
seeing and identify it and again I think
the challenge here is it's really easy
to kind of fall into giving things like
cutesy names and cutesy categories that
don't really mean anything or you know
what I kind of think of is like you know
startup like techno jargon but basically
if you're not from this world and
there's all this jargon readers and
users are not going to understand what
it is that they're looking at without
further explanation so the whole point
of navigation really is to let people
know what they're looking at and the
second part of navigation is wayfinding
it's basically to let someone know where
they are and where they can go from here
so you know again these sound like
really simple things but even having
even having a menu structure that lets
people know what part of the site
they're on it's important and I think -
especially some of the off-the-shelf
sort of content services that you use
don't really do a good job of this and I
mean our solution for this is we
essentially built our own version of
WordPress which is open source anyone
who's interested you know you can go out
there you can download it you can use it
for free it's something that we we build
and maintain and we feel really strongly
about providing open source tools for
content people for journalists for
anyone who wants to put information out
into the world but that's how our
menuing works it's all very simple it
just literally tells you the name of the
thing that you're seeing and then
somewhere at the bottom there's
wayfinding navigation